(audience cheering and clapping)
- All right, y'all.
We are back, and we always
love to shine a light
on Broadway shows making
their mark here in the city.
These days, "Kimberly Akimbo"
has been the talk of the town,
earning five Tony's last
year, the most of any show,
including Best Musical.
The show follows a
teenager with a condition
that causes her body to
age faster than it should.
So she goes through all
those trials and tribulations
of adolescence looking
like a 72-year-old woman,
and that's just the starting point.
Now, performing though,
the hopeful Act 1 finale, "This Time",
give it up for the cast
of "Kimberly Akimbo."
(audience cheering and clapping)
(gentle music)
♪ This time, oh, this time ♪
♪ Oh, this time, I put aside the doubt ♪
♪ Oh, this time, maybe things work out ♪
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music continues)
♪ This time, oh, this time ♪
♪ This time, the dead ends will end ♪
♪ This time ♪
♪ Oh, this time ♪
♪ Oh, this time, I
think I found a friend ♪
♪ It's Friday night in Bergen County ♪
♪ There are parties everywhere ♪
♪ And we finally got invited ♪
♪ This time, oh, this time ♪
♪ Oh, this time, a better life begins ♪
♪ It's Friday night in Bergen County ♪
♪ There are parties everywhere ♪
♪ This time, everybody wins ♪
♪ This time, we won't implode ♪
♪ This time, we hit the road ♪
♪ This time, we'll stay on track ♪
♪ This time, my voice won't crack ♪
♪ This time, we take the prize ♪
♪ This time, nobody dies ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ Not like the other time ♪
♪ This time, oh, this time ♪
♪ Oh, this time, no
one breaks your heart ♪
♪ This time, oh, this time ♪
♪ This time, this time ♪
♪ Oh, this time, nothing falls apart ♪
- Make a wish.
♪ I will believe ♪
(upbeat music)
♪ This time ♪
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Once more, let's hear it for the cast
of "Kimberly Akimbo", everybody.
"Kimberly Akimbo" is launching
a national tour this fall,
and you can also catch
them here in New York
on Broadway till April 28.
Get your tickets online.
And people, we'll be
right back in a moment.